guys it's alex with all cars key
programming in all cars brotherhood uh
today we're going to be working on a 22
dodge ram 1500 uh we're going to be
adding a key to the system using the
auto pro pad
um
i'm going to go ahead and show you how
we get that done where we hook up
sorry guys so you can see here it's a
you're built 10 21 makes it a 22.
all right but uh we don't hook up here
in the obd area
uh we actually have to go onto the
passenger side so
i'll show you guys how to get there
all right so i kind of pulled it down so
you can just kind of get in there you're
going to hook up right where this black
cord is follow it over the top there
and uh we're going to be adding this key
here
as you can see it doesn't work
this is the
key that works
all right so
let's go ahead and get on this auto pro
pad
make sure you get the hazard lights on
before you get started
that way it can actually uh
find the car on the auto detect
automatically identify
now if this doesn't go through on
automatic you can just actually just go
manually
and get it done that way
as you see here it says 22 ram
see us
talks about the secret security gateway
plug
all right so i'm going to read the pin
it takes just a little bit
all right there it is four eight one two
four all right
all right
i'm gonna go ahead and read the number
of keys in the system there's two so
that's what i like to do i like to see
what number how many keys are in the
system before i get started so that way
if it fails i can actually just go back
and see if the key actually learned so
let me press ok i'm going to go to
program key
48124 it's already populated
all right hold down the start button on
the upper corner of the key
so i'm gonna go ahead and look for it
there
press the button
i'm just going to hold it down
c
let me see something real quick
let me go ahead and take out the actual
original key
because it doesn't look like it's going
through
let's take this original key out of the
car and that way it's not being seen by
that put it back here
the back of the bed normally i like to
keep them outside but i kind of forgot
and then let's start that over again
here we go
press it
that still will still be able to be seen
by the other the other key give me one
second
get a little further out
hopefully that'll work
all right let's start that over again
and let's press one more time here we go
two
c
i'm not getting anything on this key
[Music]
i'm not getting the thing here
it's not seeing the foam at all
okay
maybe this one didn't go through give me
one sec we're going to start this over
again
all right guys we're back on this 22 uh
dodge ram and uh
obviously earlier we were trying to get
it to go
and it wasn't going so
what i ended up doing is i ended up like
reading the chip value or specific chip
value and it was off like
at least with the little the the mini
key tool
it came up as a
7953 mary
and the key i was trying to add in was a
7939 mary
which you know is different so
um i did find
uh another key that uh
had the 7953 mary and we're gonna go
with that um but the cool thing like i
said before like cool thing about this
is that we're
seeing that the auto pro pad is able to
communicate is able to read the pin
uh to see how many keys are in and it
wasn't the auto pro pad's fault that the
key wasn't being added
clearly it was because
the chip value is different you know so
here we're going to figure it we're
going to show you guys how to get it all
done
remember i like to write obviously see
the number of keys it says 2
and now we're going to go into program
key
yep
all right so it's going to tell me to
put the key to the start button and hold
it down
we'll do that now
let's see what that says
and program success
all right guys we're done now we're
gonna go see the number of keys
says three
all right so this key
definitely works
awesome all right guys so i just wanted
to show you guys that
um again if you guys are learning
anything
you're liking the content content please
share it
and then obviously give me a like um
if there's anything that you guys wish
to see on my videos
please leave that in the comment section
i'm always interested to see what you
guys are thoughts are
or just opinions all right guys you guys
have a good day we'll see on the next
one